after 16 years of playing the classical
guitar making recordings touring with
groups playing concerts I've encountered quite
a lot of misconceptions about this instrument
and how it's played so in today's video I
thought it'd be fun to debunk some common
classical guitar myths quick disclaimer these
are of course my opinions I do believe they're
grounded in historical fact most of them but if
you disagree let me know why in the comments also
if I missed some add them to the comments myth
number one you have to play with nails today
the common belief is that to play classical
guitar you have to grow the fingernails long
on your plucking hand usually your right hand
to pluck the strings however this wasn't always
the case the pioneering composers of the 19th
century who wrote the guitar's main repertoire
and developed this technique like sore karkazi
taraga and many others did not play with nails
now of course at the same time other players did
play with nails they're both historically that
valid but if you talk to most classical guitarists
today they'll say things like well if you want
to be a serious classical guitarist you have to
play with nails well I don't have nails and I'm a
pretty serious classical guitarist so not true for
more on this subject check out this video I made
myth number two you need nails to play tremolo
now even among those who've accepted that playing
with or without nails are both historically valid
it's often believed that to play tremolo uh you do
need Nails tremolo is this really fascinating
technique on the classical guitar where you
rapidly play four fingers in succession and
it makes a really cool effect on the guitar
now right now I'm playing without nails
sometimes I play with nails sometimes I
play without I do think it's a different
sound with nails it's a bit more of a bit
more percussive a bit more machine gun like
without nails it's a bit more Brushy but
let's remember a very important historical fact
Targa himself who wrote the most famous tremolo
piece recuerdos de la Alhambra you can check
out my performance of that piece here Targa
didn't play with nails at the end of his life
and he was a big proponent of playing without
nails he thought there was a magic to it that you
couldn't get with nails so since the man himself
Targa did it and I'm doing it right now can play
tremolo without nails foreign ly it is possible
myth number three you need big hands to play
guitar well the classical guitar is well known
for being extremely technically demanding and one
of the differences of the actual instrument when
compared to like a steel string acoustic guitar
is that the strings are wider the neck is wider
and the strings are farther apart and the neck
is a bit thicker which makes it very hard to do
things like put your thumb on top of the neck so
when students are learning very often they come to
the conclusion that you must need very big hands
to play the classical guitar but I think we can
really safely debunk this myth in my experience
I've encountered guitarists with fingers that are
so much shorter than mine so much longer than mine
so much thinner than mine so much wider than mine
every person has their own personal anatomy
and we're all so quick to blame our anatomy
when things aren't going right technically on
an instrument before you blame your Anatomy
blame technique it's almost always your Technique
segovia's hands were huge and and like one of his
fingers was like three of mine so how do they fit
it into these upper frets here I mean that must
have been uh challenging for him the point is no
matter what size and shape fingers you have I've
seen guitarists Excel so well uh and played better
than me with different size hands than me so don't
blame your Anatomy fix your Technique and by the
way we live in a good time now where you can buy
really good guitars at different sizes so if you
are on the shorter side and you do want a smaller
guitar get one the standard classical guitar
scale from here to here is 65 centimeters now
they make a lot of them that are 64 centimeters
this guitar this is a Taurus replica it is 64
centimeters you can get one that's even shorter
than that if you want you can get a 7 8 guitar
if you're buying for a 11 year old you can get
a three-quarter size guitar or even a half size
guitar so play a guitar that's right for you and
fix your Technique before you blame your Anatomy
myth number four you need strong fingers to play
the guitar very often in my lessons with students
they'll say things like oh I don't have enough
strength I need to build more muscle to to play
this well this one applies to all guitarists
one of the worst devices I've ever seen is
this finger grip strengthener that you can buy
online with springs designed to I don't know
like make little biceps you know on your on your
fingers as if we wanted muscular fingers you don't
want muscular fingers we don't play the guitar
well because we're muscular beginners don't have
weak muscles and advanced players having super
ripped fingers instead it's all about technique
it's how you use your fingers learning to use
economy of motion very often at the beginning
we're using the wrong muscles or too many muscles
we're gripping in the wrong way and therefore we
can't get the right notes down so you're playing
your F major bar chord that all guitarists find
difficult when they first come to the guitar and
they it sounds like this I can't get the notes to
sound it's not because you're too weak you're not
allocating pressure in the right way if you use
gravity the weight of the world and you hang your
arm from the guitar the bar takes care of itself
you're actually using less muscles so please don't
buy these silly finger strengthening things they
probably actually hurt you more than they help
you by the way if you need help with your bar
chords recently one of our teachers at my online
music school did a full workshop on the subject so
check out this video here it's in the link in the
description if you want to improve your bar chords
myth number five you need to tune to a equals
440 Hertz today pitch has become standardized
uh so when we say play me this a it usually
means an a at 440 Hertz I think it's that
a uh and orchestras tuned to it most of the
time and if you go to electronic keyboard or
a guitar tuner everything is calibrated around
that idea but it's important to know that for
most of History pitch was relative so what you
called an a could vary quite a lot depending on
where and when you were this a could have sounded
like this or this or this or this or this there's
quite a bit of a spectrum here within at least
a major third that all could have been called
a depending on where and when you were so you
might say so what now we have a good calculated
a let's just use that well the reason I say this
is because I would encourage people to experiment
with the pitch of their instruments with their
guitars in general for example experiment with
lowering the pitch I find that with specific
strings and specific guitars if you lower the
tuning to say 415 Hertz or everything tuned down
a half step not only is it nice because you have
a lot less tension on the strings the guitar has
a warmer sound and you might find something in
between there where the guitar actually sounds
wonderful maybe your guitar sounds best at 419
Hertz I don't know have you tried if you only ever
tune your guitar to 440 Hertz you might be missing
something so I would recommend experimenting
with the pitch today's video is brought to you
by classical guitar Pro that's my brand new online
classical guitar course which is six hours 53
videos it's a whole curriculum designed to teach
you what you would normally learn in the first
six months to a year of classical guitar lessons
so if you want to learn classical guitar but are
stuck struggling reading music or struggling to
learn the techniques check out classicalguitara
dashpro.com to learn more myth number six louder
guitars are better in my many conversations with
luthiers and guitarists one thing seems clear
the best guitars are very loud guitars and the
general trend of Guitar Building today is to
make guitars which are as loud as possible and
it makes sense why they're doing this players are
playing in bigger and bigger Halls sometimes giant
Orchestra Halls that are meant for 60 person
orchestras and rather than amplify they want a
super loud and resonant instrument so the guitars
end up being very overbuilt heavy people end up
using super super high attention strings and the
guitars are even made for it so these things are
just cannons you know the reason I'm calling
this one a myth I'm saying that the idea that
louder guitars are better is a myth is because
historically guitars are not this Canon they're
not this percussive thing that plays at you it's a
seductive Charming romantic instrument that pulls
you into its world I think we lose so much of the
charm of the instrument when we try to make it
louder louder and louder with higher and higher
tension strings I've played so many modern guitars
today where the strings are so high tension and
the instruments are made for it so that's slurs
become impossible vibrato doesn't even work on
the instrument and this means that all those
beautiful elegant light slurred passages
in classical guitar music become heavy
duty of passages like that are how easy it sounds
how graceful it is the other important historical
fact here is that guitars were never designed to
play in giant Orchestra halls with 3 000 person
audiences the guitar is an instrument made for and
perfectly suited to play in Salon Style music this
means small recitals for maybe a room full of
20 people and if everyone started talking you
wouldn't be able to hear it and in my experience
when I perform concerts often I push the audience
I play softer and softer how softly can I actually
take the music down and what I've noticed is
people kind of lean in and you can hear a pin
drop those are the most beautiful moments for me
myth number seven the more you practice the
better you'll get of course this tip applies
to all musicians but classical guitarists
have a lot of demanding music to learn a
lot of challenging techniques and so we
have to practice a lot be forewarned more
practice isn't good good quality practice
is good but you can certainly practice in
a way for hours and hours and hours that
makes you worse why is that the reason is
because muscle memory is a double-edged sword
you need it to play very complicated things
fast passages like that one require a lot
of repetition of the same movement but if
you practice the wrong things repeatedly which
so many of us do your hands will memorize those
mistakes forever your fingers don't know the
difference between the things you wanted and
the things you don't it just knows repetition
so practice slowly accurately and efficiently
show your hands only the things you want
them to repeat and then do that a lot so
no more practice doesn't make you a better
player if you're not careful it can make you
worse what you really want is quality practice
and the last thing I'll say about this one is
actually there is a point especially as we get
older where the more you practice you have to
be careful because tension in your body can lead
to fatigue and inflammation can lead to Chronic
injuries quality is always better than quantity
so thank you guys for watching again I want to
say that the topics covered in this video are
my own opinions and I am very open-minded if
you disagree with me let me know why I'm very
I'd be very curious to know where I might be
going wrong these are all just my feelings based
on what I've read researched and played so let's
get a conversation going in the comment section
what other myths are there about the classical
guitar that might need debunking if any so
please do subscribe if you haven't already
it really helps the channel you can also check out
my patreon page directly support the creation of
more videos like this in the future and
I hope to see you all next time foreign